okay four people joining this livestream
we are working on cloud infrastructure
foreign language and we are first
looking at um let's see
cloud object named format that is a very
is that what we're first looking at -
cloud object named format we could or we
could do permissions okay the actual
permissions
yeah the permissions are F page okay
let's look at that one
okay so we've added a new class to this
and the original thing we needed help
with we need some progress on that today
but basically there were just so many
details to constraints that it started
to get long for the reader before they
got to you know like the list of read
write and execute you can see is almost
down there at the bottom of the page
okay so if we've we've managed to shrink
it quite a bit
it's better possible causes of users or
requests does include all of these
okay
so
well the issue is what you want to do is
you want to say up here possible classes
of users or requesters include and then
one of the things that you're giving
here is this thing that is the
Association is that correct right okay
so you didn't listen that up here so we
need to oh we did unless you did yes the
few tries one at the end
okay I think
um
okay
I see so those are the okay fair enough
all right
boy well this is fairly complicated yes
and hopefully the examples will make it
a bit clearer what's going on so you'll
need I mean lots of examples yeah
yes right we're working on that I can
send you well I have a list of sort of
the examples for constraints that are
they're not actually they're not flush
out examples they're just sort of you
know here are the different formats that
it takes if that would be helpful
okay so this isn't right anyway so users
in a permissions group request us with
valid okay
so what this is this is supposed to be
classes of users or requesters so this
is and constraints kind of change what
it what classes means because it's now
its properties of a request requesters
let's see
satisfying constraints seven buying
specified constraints it's good so
what we want to do is here is we want to
say constraint bla bla bla
particularly may need a different thing
here um okay so what we want to say is
each one is a named constraint so it's
constraint one value one
you
well okay I was debating whether to call
that the keys a constraint or the rule
are constrained I see I think we should
call them properties
okay
um satisfying the constraint constraints
that Prop AI is equal to vowel I
or matches there's wildcards so
satisfying constraints that prop I
matches hi
you
okay
okay um
possible properties
for use and constraints
include
you
you
you
okay cloud user ID no it's not the the
user ID of the requesting user
the inferred
um our country the deduced that the
country inferred for the request country
of origin isn't inferred for the request
you
you
um
[Music]
you
let's see the way to say this is
you
actually
look why don't we do this impossible
forms of
constraints include and then what we do
is we say
[Music]
cloud user ID arrow
and then so a little lower down we have
this I know okay see just making sure
oh I see this yeah yeah the fact that
that can be so complex is and the fact
that started at end they don't really
match that is what kind of makes this
challenging request a satisfying
um okay all right so then
okay
okay possible properties all right cloud
user idea requesting user okay then we
say
oh for goodness sake
well let me see if I can document this
um
no you know what I was going to do was
was right before ok um oops possible
possible forms for
you
you
defining
and the association possible elements in
the
possession possible elements in the
association defining requesters
you
great um okay hold on
for defining
okay
now cloud user ID doesn't have any okay
um
let's call that
okay
cloud user ID
you
of the requesting user
conforms to form
okay okay now
you
okay now
okay so what this is saying is
okay um date
whoops
current date is after specified date
okay yeah
okay
so now okay so now I think we say
um
[Music]
um dates are specified using date object
um for cloud user ID and your location
country following
forms
can be used
you
okay so I think what we should do is
actually say
I would say prop arrow and then value
prop arrow
I think it's less confusing that way
yeah um
prop arrow value um yeah actually had
that my draft and I took it out later
yeah I agree
allow only the specified value
okay and then we're going to have to
have that last footnote about the wild
cards
including string patterns
not to be taken to me in countries whose
names start with M yeah I know
but that's I think it's fine yeah let's
do that okay okay
okay now we've got prop Harrow
this allowed arrow value 1 dot dot
this allow any of the value I why isn't
that an association allowed disallowed
should be sure we want dis
rather than disallow I'm not sure I
haven't thought about that one I think
we want this allow so allow and disallow
that's what I think the property is the
cloud user ID is disallow I think that's
right
you
you
now this is slightly gnarly
documentation I agree
okay
um
values for
user ID can be given as string patterns
include
wild card
okay I think you should have something
write down underneath here where you
just say um I'm just gonna make a sample
thing here um
[Music]
you
something about permissions arrow
can I say all four read/write/execute
here I think so it might mean off all of
the capabilities not just read write
execute but specify that permissions set
up permissions that allow anyone with a
home comm cloud user ID
all
capabilities
cloud user ID the Wolfram calm I think
is not me they'd actually since private
clouds no no no no no with a with a
Wolfson calm over this specific example
loud user ID right I think you should
have in this basic examples here you
should have a few more that just look
like this yeah because people will
understand that you know you just
describe what they are and get an
airline because absolutely did all of
all the stuff around here I wouldn't do
this this way I would just show and I
wouldn't use card put I would use cloud
deploy and I don't know why earth cloud
publishes and in the list of um oh yeah
well really it we could add all of the
all of the writing functions yeah I
think we should say like not sure why it
needs to say Cloud Connect actually I
think we should say cloud deploy cloud
publish cloud put
there's also cloud export a couple more
but well this cloud export affected by
this yes all of the writing functions
take permissions yeah cloud saves okay
okay you can you can yeah yes okay all
right so let's go back up here
okay so this goes away
that goes away that goes away
you
um
countries are specified as
using
right right
you
okay looks like we're done with this
let's make sure we tag these as 12 plus
so on you can do that though um okay
let's go on to the next thing before I
run out of time yeah so cloud object
name format and okay by the way I think
we might want you know some other
special cases here I mean this is pretty
straightforward this one here Volition's
you
well but the
you see I would almost argue
that you should allow a string that is
just an email address an email a list of
email oh yeah an explicit list of users
yeah yeah it does that but can those
users be be wildcards not currently no
they could do that then then you'd be in
great shape there and in fact if there
was then a single user that you could
give and it could be a wild card you
could just say now you know sort of Star
Wolf comm arrow read/write/execute
yeah yeah we've noticed the sort of
similarity between those user classes
and the constraint that just has the
cloud user ID property I think you
should do that so yeah if it's a wild
card it could be a shortcut for the
Association seems right to me yeah okay
so I'm just gonna add a few tries well I
you you can remember that okay okay
cloud object name format how many of
these how many more of these do we have
to do we just we have this with the
dollar sign variable and then cloud
object URL type with its dollar variable
have these things been knitted on to
guide pages I don't remember yeah but
I'd have to check
okay so remind me what these are so
cloud object name format its formatting
it does two things if it's a way to turn
a named object into one whose you URL is
by UUID and if it's a named object it it
chooses how to format the user name
should be for method as an option for
television writer constructs the
determines how all related objects that
determines how the objects name should
be formatted in in its URL oh yes
to reconsider this experimental or not
now okay
I met isn't the default value
you
okay looks reasonable enough um
shouldn't this refer to dollar cloud
object URL type um yeah that that
doesn't make sense yeah
you
well how the object names should be
formatted how yeah that doesn't it is is
part of the name yeah look the comment
yeah how the URL should be formatted and
related the determines how the URL for
the
how the object should be named well
you
that determines the format
okay what does it affect it affects the
the end of the name right
it's well it doesn't affect hmm there's
two possible outputs of this one is a
UUID in which case it is the end and the
other one is that if it's named then
doesn't affect the path part but it
affects how the username is formatted
okay so on it says yeah that determines
the name portion
you
you
you
the bass type of URL to
if there's a formatting or to generate
its salsa formatting but is it
generation as well does it affect the
actual value of the URL or your
formatting is the same deal about
formatting yeah it's it's just another
part of the URL no but I understand that
but I'm asking if you change it you'll
get a different okay wait a minute
specifies the base type of URL to
generate for the object okay so now okay
um
okay so we want to say here is used to
format the URL in the cloud or in a
cloud or in the cloud object expression
does not change the object since the
object but does does not change the
object itself
but does determine how
you
the cloud system um
you
will present the object
thing yeah
[Music]
okay so that should refer to
I am gonna have to go in two minutes
here um
okay why don't you follow through on
these other ones so did I just I mean is
hold on I can probably do this one
you
maybe I have that one there as far as
the changed inversion and the Knitting
no I'll have to do the Knitting I love
to do that that's fine
the fourth setting
that pickle values for you didn't finish
this it was it okay so the please fill
in the see also CL okay and and then do
you really want me to do this I okay I
can do this a couple minutes here okay
so this is
you
you
you
you
okay cloud object
you
did you put these on the cloud object
page because they're obviously options
here right you didn't put them here did
you okay so where else do they have to
be inserted
they are options to any function that I
think any function that produces a cloud
object so you have to look up these yeah
okay so we're gonna need to
you
you
so I see it future eyes done like cloud
deploy what does it say that for the the
description it says name format to use
for the published object ok URL format
to use for the cloud object you are no
format to use
what did we say here
format our tears for the Europe for the
name portion of the URL yeah
um and here we want to say
you
you
based type of URL to use obj comma and
dot dot dot right yeah
okay so that's gonna have to be copied
different places yeah okay now
you
you
who
you
I'm sorry this is gonna take me a little
bit longer to figure out
probably this wants to be and once to be
on this page we're gonna need a very
brief other meeting to sort this out
okay that's fine
um just a minute um I have to go okay
let me let me um we'll just need just a
few minutes why don't you go try and
figure out what guide pages this belongs
on okay okay all right let me go ahead
and save all the stuff out I will push
it back right now okay thank you
Thanks okay bye